this morning with my counterparts in the
G7
as well as heads of the United Nations
NATO and the European Union
I express my thanks for the solidarity
we have seen as we've stood up an
unprecedented Global effort
I updated our partners on a significant
progress we made in the past 10 days
as of this afternoon we've helped
evacuate seventy thousand seven hundred
people just since August the 14th
75 900 people since the end of July
just in the past 12 hours
another 19 U.S military flights 18 c-17s
and one C-130 carrying approximately 6
400 evacuees and 31 Coalition flights
carrying 5 600 people have left Kabul
just in the last 12 hours
a total of 50 more flights 12 000 more
people since I've updated to you this
morning
these numbers are a testament to the
efforts of our brave service women and
men to our diplomats in the ground in
Kabul and to our allies still standing
with us
and we had a productive discussion
there were strong agreement among the
leaders about both about Evacuate the
evacuation Mission underway as well as
the need to coordinate our approach to
the Afghan to Afghanistan as we move
forward
first on evacuation
we agreed that we will continue to close
our close cooperation to get people out
as efficiently and safely as possible
we are currently on a pace to finish by
August the 31st the sooner we can finish
the better
each day of operations brings at risk to
our troops
but
the completion by August 31st depends
upon the Taliban continuing to cooperate
and allow access to the airport for
those who were trans were transporting
out and no disruptions to our operations
in addition I've asked the Pentagon and
the state department for contingency
plans to adjust the timetable should
that become necessary
I'm determined to ensure that we
complete our mission this mission
I'm also mindful of the increasing risks
that I've been I've been uh briefed on
and the need to factor those re those
risks in they're real and significant
challenges that we also have to take
into consideration the longer we stay
starting with the acute and growing risk
of an attack by a terrorist group known
as Isis k
a nicest affiliate in Afghanistan which
is the sworn enemy of the Taliban as
well
every day we're on the ground there's
another day we know that Isis K is
seeking to Target the airport and attack
both U.S and Allied Forces and innocent
civilians
additionally
thus far the Taliban had been taking
steps to work with us so we can get our
people out
but it's a tenuous situation
or already had some gun fighting break
out
we run a serious risk of it breaking
down as time goes on
second
the G7 leaders and the leaders of the EU
NATO and the UN all agreed that we will
stand United in our approach to the
Taliban
we agreed the legitimacy of any future
government depends on the approach it
now takes to uphold International
obligations including to prevent
Afghanistan from being used as a base
for terrorism
and we agree that none of us
are going to take the taliban's word for
it we'll judge them by their actions and
will stay in close coordination on any
steps that we take moving forward in
response to the taliban's behavior
at the same time we renewed our
humanitarian commitment to the Afghan
people
and supported a proposal by the
Secretary General Gutierrez of the
United Nations LED International
response with unfettered humanitarian
access in Afghanistan
third we talked about our mutual
obligation to support refugees and
evacuees currently fleeing Afghanistan
the United States will be a leader in
these efforts
and we'll look to the International
Community and to our partners to do the
same
we're already seeing our allies
commitment
they're bringing their they're bringing
to their countries the Afghans who
served alongside their forces as
translators are in their embassies just
as we're bringing to the United States
those Afghans who worked alongside our
forces and diplomats we're continuing
that effort we're conducting
thoroughs security screening and the
intermediate stops they're making for
anyone who is not a U.S citizen or a
lawful permanent resident of the United
States
anyone arriving in the United States
will have undergone a background check
and and we must all work together to
resettle thousands of Afghans to
ultimately qualify for Refugee status
the United States will do our part and
we are already working closely with
Refugee organizations to rebuild the
system that was purposefully destroyed
by my predecessor
finally we agreed to stay vigilant
against terrorist threats that have
metastasized around the world
we went to Afghanistan with our allies
in 2001 for Clear reasons one to get the
people who attacked us on 9 11 and to
get Osama bin Laden and to make sure
that Afghanistan was not used again as a
base from which to attack the United
States or our allies
we achieved that objective
we delivered Justice to Bin Laden more
than a decade ago
but the current environment looks very
different than it did in 2001.
and we have to meet the challenges we
face today
we run effective counter-terrorism
operations around the world
where we know terrorism is more of a
threat than it is today in Afghanistan
without any permanent military presence
on the ground
and we can and will do the same thing in
Afghanistan both are over the horizon
counterterrorism capability
cooperation with our closest Partners on
our enduring counterterrorism Mission
will continue to be an essential piece
of our strategy
in short we all all of us agreed today
that we're going to stand shoulder to
shoulder with our closest Partners to
meet the current challenges we face in
Afghanistan just as we have for the past
20 years
we're acting in consultation and
cooperation with our closest friends and
fellow democracies
and I want to again thank all of our
allies and partners around the world who
have rallied in support of our shared
mission
we ended the conversation today by a
clear statement on all of our parts we
are going to stay United locked at the
hip in terms of what we have to do
we'll get that done